is the right-hander roberto castellanos
the native of mexico 23 year old
right-hander unbeaten in three starts
this month yeah and he's gonna have his
work cut out for him today he's gonna
have to mix it up quite a bit this is a
pretty good lineup here the dodgers are
running out there today he's gonna have
to change a lot of speeds up there at
the on the mound
and that is ball four four pitch walk
first and second and nobody out on the
top of the first inning
[Applause]
double play ball here rojas martay turns
it
so mookie at third two down the
dangerous clean-up pinner is max muncie
the 3-2 pitch to muncie
and a fly ball get to center field for
varshall he's under it
and he's got it nice job by castianos
here's tony who's
sporting some adjusted facial hair i'm
sure a lot of that had to do with you
know them dressing up too so
we'll tell you
why he did that a little bit later
rojas in the air to left field
going back is
aj what a catch aj pollock
tremendous defense
when he's been healthy
he ropes this one into right field and
mickey betts hanging around makes the
catch two down
and tony gets him swinging so three up
three down some great defense from aj
[ __ ]
for the fly ball to right center field
racing on back is calhoun he can't get
it one hop to the wall in front of the
swimming pool
and a lead off double for will smith
here in the second inning so man at
second base justin turner
here's a shot to right center field in
the 3-2 pitch smith will touch third
he's headed to the plate
and the relay throw will be cut off and
the dodgers have a one-nothing lead
justin turner driving in his 83rd run of
the season so the dodgers with the quick
one to nothing lead so here's aj pollock
astianis delivers
and there's a fly ball to left field
well hit on its way and it is gone a
home run
aj pollock a two run shot his 17th of
the year and the dodgers have a quick
three to nothing lead here in the top
half of the second he's coming off a one
two three first and cole calhoun gets us
started in the second
cole calhoun hits a high fly ball to
right field mookie betts is at the wall
and it's gone
diamondbacks answer right back that's
number five for cole calhoun with a 1-1
count
and hits this one hard on the ground of
muncie right along the line
swings and misses the bat goes flying
and he is done that's a second strikeout
for gonzalon
got him swinging
to the left side into short left field
pollock is now coming in as seeger is
racing out seeger fears off at the last
moment
slider he swings and misses badly and
that's the second out
got him with a splitter and he is out
five strikeouts for tony gonzalez
through three innings
[Applause]
couldn't check takes a funny swing at
that curveball
and that's the first strikeout for
castellanos
and it's popped up to center
marshall on the run out there and he'll
flag it down
bounced up the middle martay behind the
bag castigato settling down he set down
seven straight
[Applause]
and martay first ball swinging pops it
up aj pollock getting plenty of work
already in the game records the first
out
and
this one is hit well into right center
field in order to get it gavin lux oh
play by lux
and marshall is going to get doubled off
easily
wow what a double play
gavin lux
easy to say his best play as an
outfielder in the big leagues
[Applause]
[Music]
josh van meter is on deck and the o1 is
a ground ball
backhanded at
[Applause]
second base by trade turner but with the
shift on there was nobody for him to
throw to at second
well let's see if van meter can get a
two-hot hit here and cut this lead down
to a run
and there's a base hit left field
pollock charges he will uh come up
throwing the ball will be all the way
through
and on the play now van meter holds it
first gets back and he is safe there a
run bounded in for van meter to make it
a 3-2 ball game
godzilla now will deliver this one home
to mccarthy
swing and i miss he got him
and turner lines running into left field
gonna roll to the corner
and the speedy trey turner arrives at
second base with a stand-up double
and he swings and he hits the ball well
to left field but he'll hang up there
for peralta
tagging and scoring
is turner the dodgers lead it four to
two on a sacrifice fly by will smith
first and third
gavin lux is the hitter
call strike three another big out for
joe man to play he rings up lux
shoots one the other way down the line
that's a fair ball in the corner
that's over to fish it out of there
martay will stop at second a
one-on-double
peralta go for two he's twice grounded
out to first
2-2
got him swinging
with the diamondbacks trailing 4-2
seeger
bangs a base hit into the right field
corner pass at diving paving smith and
now seeger is on his way to third with a
head first fight he will make it
breaking ball down to third here comes
that play damier to the first got him on
a nice play to end the inning
[Applause]
so now they're loaded here comes taylor
got him tyler clifford with a splitter
he leaves him loaded it's still 4-2
serbiantes in effect
volcano and cole calhoun 3-2 marta at
sega base roasted third treyman's payoff
pitch
flying on a miss strike three got him
only three for 24 against janssen in his
career but he does have a home run
[Applause]
had to go out there again this one
lifted the left and a diving stop oh
what a play by chris taylor robbing
extra bases now the banner is paving
smith who has struck out three times
tonight
[Applause]
[Music]
in a long run for taylor again who makes
the catch chris tanner putting on a
clinic carson kelly last man standing
janssen on one and two here it comes tug
on and miss strike three the dodgers win
number 99